foreign
[Music]
so that's what Pandora actually looks
like James Cameron's Avatar is one of
the most visually stunning films ever
made but what does it look like without
all the CGI the animators have taken
what the actors are doing and gone even
beyond that natiri lives a pretty unique
lifestyle as one of the Navi on the
planet of Pandora one of the things that
we see natiri partake in is drinking
water from a leaf but because director
James Cameron loves to rely on
Technology Innovation the way that the
scene was actually filmed without CGI
may surprise you Zoe Saldana was
required to work with a gray plastic
Contraption to model as the leaf while
holding a water bottle covered in duct
tape to simulate water coming from the
tape we guess that's why they call it
movie Magic it's the most high-tech film
in terms of its execution you may or may
not have had an awkward kiss in your
life but it probably wasn't as awkward
as it was for Sam Worthington and Zoe
Saldana when they had to kiss as Jake
and natiri while filming Avatar while in
the movie itself with all the added CGI
the scene plays out romantically without
all the CGI Worthington and Saldana had
to kiss with their motion captured
jumpsuits and with green dots all over
their face so that the motion capture on
their character's CGI bodies would be
accurate and more real we created a
manually operated gimbal rig that they
could balance on one of the most
exciting action scenes in all of Avatar
was definitely the flying Banshee
obviously a lot of CGI was needed to be
done to bring the Banshee to life as
there's no living real world counterpart
to the creature in order to capture Jake
flying on the Banshee Sam Worthington
was required to fly on the back of a
moving plastic structure where he'd be
flung around with wires all while
wearing the motion capture suit honestly
we think we just prefer the ride at
Disney world that seems a bit more
comfortable see them flying these things
they're working hard it's always intense
whenever anybody in a movie yells but
when a blue-skinned alien like natiri
yells it's even more powerful
to be one of the people despite the
goofy motion capture getup and the silly
plastic Navi ears Saldana was still able
to be quite intimidating on set layers
of additional CGI were added in order to
make natiri and the rest of the navi
look even more real in the film you
definitely wouldn't want to take natiri
off I at least have no idea that I'm
wearing this I feel like I'm blue and
I'm nine feet tall the big villain of
Avatar was Stephen Lang's Colonel Miles
quarrich who unlike a lot of the other
characters who required CG is actually a
human one might assume that the
Colonel's Mac suit design was all CGI
but they would be wrong the main core
design of the suit was a practical
effect but it was the arm and the
digital screens that were later added
with additional CGI work in order to
make the suit a more formidable Force to
the navi the final product proved to be
quite the treat to the navi and made
Lang's Colonel an even more memorable
villain with rumors that he'll be back
for the sequel he may even bring that
neck suit back oh yeah who's bad that's
right one of the first dangerous
creatures that Jake Encounters in the
jungles of Pandora is the fierce
thanatore while the thanatore is quite
intimidating on screen the creature
wasn't much to look at before the CGI
was added in fact before the CGI was
added standing in for the thanator was a
red tennis ball on a long gray stick
held by a crew member in order for the
actors to go on cue the crew member
holding the thanatore's stand-in would
lunge at them life on Pandora would
likely be much easier if all the navi
had to worry about was a tennis ball on
a stick Cameron has a knack for working
with actors and actresses he's worked
with before so of course one of the
actresses he brought with him to Avatar
was his alien star Sigourney Weaver
Weaver plays Grace in the film and
doesn't just play the character in human
form but also as a Naveed while even in
her Navi form Grace typically wears
human clothes behind the scenes Weaver
had to still wear a motion capture suit
to convincingly play Grace's Navi avatar
from Alien to ghost Fosters Sigourney
Weaver has clearly made her Mark in the
Sci-Fi genre we had horses galloping
around this place it wasn't just the
human actors who were behind motion
capture technology on the set of Avatar
as actual horses were used under motion
capture technology for the dire horses
the horses were equipped with dots on
their body much like their human
co-stars in order for them to be
transformed later with visual effects
the horses were brought to the Sound
Stage of the film and Cameron would film
the actors behind the navi riding the
horses with the special technology that
would allow him to be their CGI
counterparts as they were filming who
knows maybe those horses went on to take
other motion capture roles as well
despite all the extensive CGI and motion
capture present throughout Avatar that
didn't mean the actors had to perform
less stunts in fact it was quite the
opposite whenever we saw the navi
climbing up the vines of the ominous
floating rocks on Pandora Cameron had
the actors behind the navi climb a
similar structure all in their motion
capture gear the final CGI was added
later but still that didn't make the
climb not dangerous though you can't
really become one of the navi without at
least getting a little bit rugged with
yourself and your environment motion
capture wasn't always available when
capturing scenes with the navi
especially when they shared the screen
with the human characters when recording
the scene where Jake first wakes up in
his Navi form Cameron filmed the actors
playing the human doctors working around
an empty Gurney behind the lens of
Cameron's camera he was able to see the
CGI character we went to Kauai we went
way up in the mountains and we acted out
the scenes before the motion capture
work was done for Avatar Sam Worthington
and Zoe Saldana filmed without their
suits half naked in Hawaii this would be
done in order so James Cameron could
know how to plan all their scenes that
would need motion capture such as the
bow and arrow scene the tree of voices
is perhaps one of the most gorgeous
looking set pieces in all of Avatar but
behind the scenes and without the CGI
that sacred tree wasn't much to look at
in fact the trees were mainly just
pieces of rope that were used to
simulate the long leaves and branches of
the trees that natiri would present to
Jake the final CGI would be added into
the production later to say these stunt
guys I mean they really just they gave
us their all the navi clearly have a
different culture than what we're used
to and Cameron wanted to display some of
the tribal customs of the main tribe in
the film the group of four actors may
not have had the biggest roles in the
film but that didn't mean their work
wasn't difficult these actors ultimately
had to memorize a tribal Dance of the
navi in all their motion capture Suits
now that's true commitment to the craft
if this was CG could have moved that 30
seconds so the whole time I was shooting
the virtual camera I was complaining
that it wasn't live action well there
were times on set where James Cameron
and his crew had more accurate models of
the Dragon assault ships there were
times where the models wouldn't be
enough in order to film the scene
Cameron had the motion capture board use
a metal-like chair in the middle of the
set that would be moved around by crew
members a fan was also placed in front
of the actors in order to properly
capture the wind blowing in their
characters faces while the real set may
not have been as exciting as actually
flying on a ship as a Navi on Pandora
the cast and crew certainly made the
most of it it developed the most
lightweight 3D system possible so it's
very sophisticated technology the 3D
much like the CGI had to be recorded in
a distinct way using two cameras this
scene where the kernel was attacked on
his Mech by one of the navi used two
cameras to perfect the 3D and the CGI
One camera would be used for the live
action elements and the other would be
used for the CG 3D l elements I need you
to put up 10 million dollars to prove we
can make this movie
[Music]
as on screen with camera people running
around and intense visual effects being
produced live
Linda
the glass stones ending definitely
caught us off guard but the process to
capture the way it surprised Guion
sebiak and sang woo was an extensive one
filming the actors only had a small
amount of glass explode near them the
slow motion feeling really comes through
and how the actors perform
after capturing shots of the trio each
got to do their close-up work with
singles as well it may be a short moment
but plenty of hours were put into
capturing every nuance and angle
when time came for the big visual of the
glass Stepping Stones we see exploding
the team didn't resort to CGI for the
shards of glass except for the ones that
appeared to harm the players and fly
towards the camera they actually went
ahead and created the whole sequence in
studio these practical effects look
unreal on the set it's no surprise it
translates to such a powerful and
stunning visual in the episode
hello player let me welcome you all to
the fifth game
the cast of squid game Dove right in
when playing glass stepping stones and
definitely didn't have it easy since for
many it was actually terrifying to film
while CGI came into play in terms of
establishing the setting and just how
high in the air the players were much of
the carnival-like set was fully built
even the glass fortunately no one
actually went through shattering glass
instead landing on a board supported by
a crew to allow the actor to fall safely
foreign
in the show the set that red light green
light takes place on already seems
awfully crowded with the nearly 500
players but on the set there were even
more folks making it a pretty chaotic
yet well-organized space we would have
thought CGI was used to add the bodies
of those who lost during the game
especially the piles of people at the
doors but the actors all actually stayed
wherever they were when they lost the
game which couldn't have been very
comfortable when it came to filming
close-ups multiple cameras were used to
capture the performances and the filming
crew was often running along with the
players the added detail of using a red
marker to Signal when a person took a
shot is evident of just how thorough and
meticulous the team was no one could get
away with cheating during the game
either if one person moved out of time
we're looking at you sang woo then
everyone had to start over
today's game is tug of war the
performers did not have it easy playing
the often physically demanding games
when filming the series since they
really were going through the struggle
depicted on screen the sweat effort and
even chained handcuffs securing them to
the Rope were real there definitely
couldn't be much movement between tanks
since everyone was literally tied up
together with a scene like this there
isn't really any other way to do it than
at 100 percent
move before you die maybe one of the
most terrifying gasp worthy moments in
the show is seeing gion hanging between
safety and the end of the game for his
whole team the tension is real even
though the platform they were on was
just a meter and a half off the ground
while swinging on a rope is usually
pretty fun this Collective ropes swing
down tells a very different story and
shows just how far the actors and
production went to bring the best
footage to the screen oh my God I can't
believe how cool that was the moment
after the most intense tug of war we've
ever seen is so still but we can see
just how exhausted each and every actor
is having just struggled and fought for
their lives literally this shot is
definitely needed as a moment of pause
after the insane game just played
resulting in so many lives lost this is
also a bit of a moment of Reckoning this
was hard but whatever was coming next
would only be harder and they knew it
what I really thought we were going to
die out there for the final Face-Off The
Sound Stage was a lot emptier with just
gion and Seng woo competing but there
were many camera people often filming
using handheld video cameras to capture
all the Frantic action not only that
their crew made it rain making the whole
scene just as dramatic as the gruesome
fight we see in the Final Cut as filming
went on the two actors only got more
disheveled with Reigns soaking through
and blood effects added throughout the
battle in order to get all the footage
they needed the actors had to be on
point at every moment
I will let you
let you get money the honeycomb scenes
looked pretty similar on set as they did
in the show with the exception of the
childlike drawn wallpaper the rest of
the set was filled with giant playground
equipment and the smell of freshly made
delgona the Korean honeycomb Suite
luckily the actors didn't have to listen
to the actual loud noise each time a
bullet was fired as someone on set was
in charge of giving a shout to indicate
the moment instead so the performers had
a solid unified cue to react to
behind the scenes we get a glimpse of
just how Hands-On the director was when
it came time to shoot
foreign
ly the cavernous cool space where we see
the confrontation between the police
officer and a team member of the squid
game is real the opening on the top of
the cave and the murky pool made the
ideal setting no doubt the actors felt
totally immersed in the story shooting
these scenes were pretty simple all they
needed were a couple of cameras the
right costumes and the actors chilling
performances
do you want to die
the glimpses we get of the players as
lives before the game offers such a
colorful backstory especially when we
see them with their families each of
these scenes were shot quite intimately
and simply focusing on the narrative and
what these relationships meant to the
player which translated to the screen
beautifully it's also one of the only
times we get to see a typical everyday
aesthetic making the stark contrast
between the real world and the squid
game world even more apparent
which color do you want to play as
how could we forget the original squid
game filming this scene may have been
one of the simplest setups using an
existing playground space it only adds
to the realism of the show and offers a
great reminder of where the players
started as innocent children playing
games for fun instead of their lives
at that moment I felt as if I owned the
entire world hanging out in the dorms
between games certainly wasn't any less
stressful than the games themselves
The Bare Bones set with the cool
industrial Edge does the trick and the
feeling of the daunting space comes
through the screen what we saw in the
show was almost exactly what was
happening on set with all the added
cameras and crew people of course
we can't fall asleep tonight okay who
knows what someone else may try many
moments in the marbles game bring
intense connection and emotion the way
they shot these scenes was a pretty
Stark difference from so many of the
large and intense games the fact that
the actors were in a small space
together with just a few crew members
around really helps the intimacy come
through and offers us the chance to get
up close and personal with these
characters and the short but meaningful
relationship they have playing marbles
one of the reasons the marbles game is
so effective is because of just how well
the setting transports us to the alleys
of a small village it makes sense that
this is the set the team spent the most
time building every detail down to the
stunning backdrops moves us it's no
surprise they got the performances they
did the authenticity of this world is
remarkable
my wife and I have this one here so like
have you guys ever wondered what John
Wick looks like under all that CGI well
ever since I found these behind the
scenes videos of how they make the John
Wick movies I've been obsessed and it's
not just because I'm a big Keanu Reeves
fan I'm a huge Keanu Reeves fan
I know that if you're watching this
you're a big piano fan too which is why
you'll be happy to know that he actually
did all his own stunts for the John Wick
movies no CGI there at all he can do
everything he's just as good
even at
is a professionally trained martial
artist but he didn't get those Mad
Skills from taking a spin class and
being over 50 the physical limitations
that one gets at that age has to be
overcome with even more hours of
physical
Fitness for five months before filming
he literally trained eight hours a day
for five days a week that's like working
out as a full-time job when we train
them we'll go for hours and hours and
hours and he just
stop during those five months Keanu
focused on fighting martial arts and all
sorts of totally awesome moves you don't
get to show up and do what he does
without having a stellar work ethic and
obviously he's also a certified Stunt
Driver he's a Phenom driver and Stunt
Driver and that allowed us to be able to
put him in a lot more of the shops it
took them like three months to
choreograph this taxi Warehouse scene
with Keanu at the wheel the whole time
if Tokyo drifted through the streets of
Manhattan wasn't cool enough the stunt
team also elevated this ramp to give the
Mustang some serious air when it
launched onto the street although I'm
not sure I'd feel totally safe if he was
my Uber driver no offense Keanu okay
confession time Keanu Reeves doesn't do
all his own stunts well yeah I could get
hit by a car but you know hospital when
a scene demands just a bit more action
than Keanu can give he calls in the pros
for some backup John Wick will get hit
by a car and that's Jackson spidell you
guys just a side note Jackson spidell is
like the king of stunts besides John
Wick he's been in a ton of Marvel movies
honestly I think he's too cute to be a
stunt actor but that's just me sorry
Moving on but speaking of cute
is that the dog
he likes you no CGI here the John Wick
dogs are totally real as far as dog
movies that I've worked on this is one
of the most
apparently there's this Corporation
Called animal actors International
that's like this database of animals who
act I wonder if Danny DeVito is
represented by them kidding we love you
Danny but that's where the John Wick
people found all their canine actors who
honestly all deserve Oscars they're so
talented a very special Beagle named
Andy played the part of Daisy who
unfortunately had a limited amount of
screen time I'll tell you what happened
to Andy after they finished filming John
Wick in a sec but first I gotta touch on
the CGI so we all know CGI can be used
for a ton of different things even stuff
you wouldn't expect like lighting
de-aging technology sorry shiny Robert
De Niro fog even kissing we set such
higher standards on the first two movies
that you always have to kind of one up
with it but apparently this technology
is a lot more complicated than I thought
we got to put things on the edge of
what's real and still make it cinematic
okay I know most of the CGI and the John
with movies are super legit but there
there was one thing they faked that I
just couldn't get over this right here
was CGI and it cost the filmmakers five
thousand dollars seriously guys couldn't
you just get chocolate or something well
they did spend the rest of that 25
million dollar budget pretty well though
it sucks did you know green screens are
green because green is the furthest
color away from many different skin
tones so when cgi's added in post the
character's skin won't get canceled out
in the Final Cut so does that mean I
should wear as much green as possible if
I'm camera shy well what if I want to be
totally invisible I should probably wear
one of these full body green screen
outfits the VFX team used to film this
motorcycle scene yeah we just wanted to
put some dudes in green suits really it
was pretty great I just wanted to
embarrass the stunt team this motorcycle
scene was actually inspired by a similar
fight scene from the 2017 South Korean
film The villainous which Keanu and John
Wick director Chad stachowski had both
seen and loved we started trying to
figure it out and we're like oh this is
what they did this is really interesting
it was like a puzzle we tried to piece
together well I'll tell you why this was
the most difficult scene to film but
first I gotta give you that update on
Andy the Beagle well shortly after Andy
retired from Show Business he was
adopted into a loving family who renamed
him Wick that's so cute Daisy
of course dogs weren't the only live
animal on the set of John Wick do you
guys remember when Keanu rides a literal
horse throughout the streets of the city
not only did Keanu have to learn stunt
driving for these films he also had to
learn stunt horse riding Chad was like
time to train on a horse for real it's
all legit it's it's John Wick it's like
it's just instead of just riding a horse
you have to have a gun fight well
apparently it took Keanu hundreds of
hours to learn how to ride but that just
goes to show how talented and devoted he
really is riding a horse was too easy
for Keanu Reeves so we had him do trick
riding ain't that one good looking
Cowboy Christmas been something we've
been working on for a couple months to
try and get this thing right so the
motorcycle fight scenes were definitely
the most difficult scenes to shoot we
have a CGI sequence it's been
challenging because it's so outside of
what we normally do the filmmakers used
a combination of Studio green screen
stunts the stunt team worked at the
choreography first and then everything
else will come after that and live
action shots on location in New York for
some high speed action I'm serious they
had stunt bikers going over 100
kilometers an hour for these shots then
they cgi'd keanu's face onto one of the
stunt drivers for the final cut
everything we did had to have a visceral
reaction to the audience okay guys now
this is some real movie Magic for this
motorcycle scene in particular the VFX
team had to add CGI to shots that were 1
000 frames long that's 1 000 different
images that had to be altered
individually and seamlessly edited
together to create a continue newest
image and here I thought editing
Instagram reels was like serious editing
there's more of a partnership with
stunts and visual effects than people
know turns out there's no chat GPT for
movie making a computer make me an epic
fight sequence so how do they make it
safe for the actors to pull off these
sweet moves you remember that famous
fight scene that seemed to take place in
that knife Museum well all that glass
special effects well some of it was real
also special custom made glass to show
up better on screen and only explode on
cue it was visually edited in post by
the VFX Department to give it that shiny
cinematic look so many of the physical
props in John Wick were real which
probably made it easier for the audience
to get lost in the magic of John Wick
well I can't help but be totally
impressed with these actors like how
hard would it be to keep a straight face
while you're doing this kind of scene I
think if there's any other action actor
or actor there wouldn't be a John work I
think he's the only one that could play
him alright I literally didn't think it
was possible for me to love Keanu Reeves
any more than I already did sometimes
life has a funny way of surprising you I
guess
from epic battle scenes impenetrable
costumes and impossible stunts Marvel
constantly has their fans Jaws dropping
with 98 of the footage from the MCU
films being sent to the special effects
editing professionals it isn't hard to
imagine how different our favorite
Avengers look behind the scenes but
imagining and seeing are two different
things from end game to wandavision and
Peter Parker in between you won't
believe how dramatically different these
Marvel scenes look without the power of
VFX and CGI just a big chocolate missile
how iconic was this girl power moment in
Avengers end game however while it may
have come together seamlessly on screen
the arrival of the female Avengers took
a bit more extra work behind the scenes
as you can see here each Avenger had to
be added in almost one by one some of
them were included using special effects
and others just popped up from
underneath the camera's View
you got something for me Captain
America's encounter with himself while
searching for the Infinity Stones was
already mind-boggling but watching how
they filmed the scene hurt our brains
even more Chris Evans filmed both parts
individually with his stunt double
swapping rolls between takes the editors
did their magic later on to make it seem
as if it truly was a double trouble
situation
I can do this all day yeah I know
although heartbreaking watching Tony
Stark's sacrifice again is worth it just
to see how it looked behind the scenes
there was actually no Infinity glove no
battle raging around him and no Thanos
looming over him just rdj's pure talent
this Vision versus Vision fight in Wanda
Vision took a lot of work Paul badine
filmed this scene with his stunt double
and they later digitally enhanced his
stunt doubles face to look like Paul
instead you can also see that the upper
part of vision's suit as well as the
environment around them was added in
later with special effects
but I'm not the true vision
getting to see the true strength of
Wanda's powers in Wanda Vision was epic
but the cast and crew weren't treated to
the same experience while Elizabeth
Olsen was filming without special
effects Wanda's combustion in the
Westview Town Square kinda looked a
little like an adult temper tantrum but
it's still impressive to think about how
it all came together in the end
[Music]
this scene had our heart rates spiking
but we're glad to know Tom Holland
wasn't in any danger filming it behind
the scenes thanos's ship was actually
just a green screen wall that Tom
Holland was climbing while attached to a
wire and wearing a motion capture suit
we're too high up you're running out of
air
the final battle was much less
anticlimactic behind the scenes than on
screen the majority of the time the cast
wasn't even on set with one another at
the same time the day where the Avengers
charged was when they had the most
people on set and even that pales in
comparison to all the digital enemies we
saw in the Final Cut if you look closely
you'll see the Avenger Army charged into
a green screen
filming Black Widow and her motorcycle
was an event that included a Harley bike
specifically created for the film stunt
doubles and motorcycle cameras for
close-up shots they would film Scarlett
Johansson at a standstill but for action
shocks they had her stunt double weaving
in and out of cars while two cameras
followed in front and behind on
motorcycles of Their Own
boys
not all special effects are done with
VFX especially in the First episodes of
One Division they swapped out Wanda's
red waves of power for Strings poles and
simple speed adjustments to achieve that
perfect 1950s Style
well please eat before it gets cold
sorry to disappoint but Thanos not real
not even behind the scenes in order to
bring him to life Josh Brolin had to
wear a big motion capture suit which
made his Battle For The Infinity
Gauntlet with Captain America in end
game a little awkward without all of the
special effects Captain America's shield
was also added with VFX meaning while
filming it was basically Chris Evans
throwing an imaginary weapon at Josh
Brolin while he pretended to get hit all
six stones
living on a land full of vibranium would
be epic but unfortunately wakanda was
all green screen and special effects
including their futuristic planes
however they still tried to make filming
as realistic as possible like the fight
scene between t'challa and umbaku where
the set designer created a pretty
realistic base for the shoot
glory to Hanuman
Dr Strange's cape for a lot of the
scenes wasn't actually there Benedict
Cumberbatch would go through the motions
of grabbing and putting on the cape but
it was added in later on using special
effects they just couldn't recreate how
life-like it was without help from the
digital realm however in other scenes
where it wasn't the main focus it was
just a part of Benedict's costume
oh
Mark Ruffalo has expressed in the past
how embarrassing it sometimes was to be
dressed in a large motion capture suit
around the rest of the Avengers cast
while we admit it looks a bit odd it was
also that the editing team could do
their magic like in this scene with the
Hulk and the ancient one he's wearing
his suit but also standing on an
elevated surface in a green screen
Studio instead of New York
Hulk
smash
it's obvious to see that the Spider-Man
illusion battle was completely done
using digital effects thanks to the
company frame store however how did they
get Spider-Man to move so much like Tom
Holland well they made sure that they
filmed the stunts and movements with Tom
in a motion capture suit so that they'd
be able to add the extra realism to the
scene Zendaya's part was also added into
the digital sequence later on we saw
plenty of different versions of vision
in Wanda Vision however what we didn't
realize is that for a portion of the
series he was actually blue Avatar blue
the showrunners worked with the makeup
Department to find what color paint
would look the best translated in black
and white turns out blue looked much
better than maroon and they stuck with
the color through every black and white
scene he shot
humans are odd valkyrie's entrance was
intense but when you take a peek behind
the curtains the intensity is deflated
the horse she was riding was actually
just an animatronic and the area around
her was completely green screen even
Wanda's magical drop down was done with
just Elizabeth Olsen and a harness
as much as we wish these portals were
real those magic rings we see in Doctor
Strange are actually just shiny metal
circles with a green screen backdrop
they were elevated to give the effects
of the actors stepping in and did help
them meet their marks evidently adding a
little more realism to it all
hi everyone
I hope to get Captain Marvel in the air
involved a lot of VFX green screen and
major dedication from Brie Larson the
actress was attached to a Contraption
made of poles that allowed the film crew
to rotate her and manipulate her in any
direction they needed this was all done
in front of a green screen so that her
powers location and even part of her
suit could be added in during
post-production it takes a lot to make a
superhero look fabulous
the Spider-Man cast didn't actually film
in London at least for this battle scene
and Far From Home the VFX team created a
digital London for the film while the
actors performed in a studio with
minimal props and structures compared to
what we see in the Final Cut
sorry to break the illusion but Iron
Man's suit wasn't actually physically
there the majority of the time often
times RDJ would just wear part of the
armor on top of a motion capture suit
there were other scenes where he would
wear a physically larger suit with his
helmet being the only part added with
VFX it really depended on what the
script required of him that day
is everything a joke to you funny things
the Marvel creators got to spend extra
time playing around with Falcon for his
new series Falcon and the Winter Soldier
and we aren't complaining they put in
the work researching and using footage
from skydivers in order to get the
perfect look for the Falcons flying
scenes they seamlessly fit together raw
shots and digital Creations to give us
these shots
getting Chris Evans to look a lot
smaller than he really was was a
challenge the production team had to go
through multiple steps first the scene
was filmed with body double Leander
deeney who still had to diet for the
role they then digitally replaced his
face with Chris Evans in editing
sometimes they would even have to scale
down the actor compared to the
environment depending on the scene Iron
Man wasn't the only one with cool
gadgets at his expense we got to see
Happy's plane in Spider-Man far from
home and we were just as impressed as
Peter Parker however behind the scenes
the plane didn't really exist while they
did build part of the Interior as a set
the majority was created digitally
watching how they filmed the Rocket
Raccoon scenes is kind of unsettling
take a look rocket was of course created
digitally but in order to capture
realistic movements Sean Gunn the
director's brother acted out the scenes
in a motion capture suit because of the
animal-like movement he was able to
replicate
the vulture wasn't slick and fast which
means the Spider-Man filmmakers needed
to make sure the vulture's special
effects portrayed his heaviness it
required some research on how humans
look flying with jet packs so that they
could replicate it and then add in those
digitally created wings
[Music]
if you're not over how epic Black Widow
is raise your hand while there's no
doubt Scarlett Johansson brought Natasha
Romanov to life perfectly it couldn't
have been done without the Added Touch
of special effects so what exactly does
black widow's butt kicking and
motorcycle riding look like without the
help of CGI stunt doubles and VFX we'll
give you a hint drastically different
it's not up to you
what would an Avengers film be without
an epic slo-mo walk sequence while this
end game scene may seem straightforward
at first glance watching the behind the
scenes footage will tell you otherwise
the VFX team played a huge role in the
Moment by adding in their white time
traveling suits while filming all of the
actors including Scarlett were wearing
motion capture suits instead the special
effects team actually helped out the
costume Department with this one the
design for the costume wasn't complete
yet so they decided on adding it
digitally
black widow's big face reveal while
acting as councilwoman Holly had a shook
but it probably left you with a lot of
how questions Scarlett along with
Holly's actress Jenny Agata both filmed
this scene separately on a green screen
and then the rest was left to the
magical powers of VFX to sync and create
that transition can you give her a
lesson
if you can impress Tony Stark you know
you're doing something right Scarlett
performed this entire fight scene with
happy herself it did take quite a few
weeks of training with her stunt double
Heidi Money Maker but by the end of it
she was flipping John Favreau on his
back like it was her job it kind of was
although Heidi did admit there was a
part of the fight sequence that she had
to jump in and film herself the stunt
included a one-handed cartwheel that led
to her legs around his neck so that she
was able to push him to the ground and
flip him over
the truth is during this Age of Ultron
scene Scarlett Johansson was barely
present some shots were done using a
motorcycle rig and an enormous green
screen background others were
complemented with additional footage
that was added on with VFX later on and
Captain America's shield without special
effects it was nothing more than a
tennis ball the coolest part about the
scene though might be the fact that
Scarlett and her stunt double were made
custom motorcycles just for the Marvel
films
stunt double Heidi had to take over for
a lot of this epic hallway sequence in
Iron Man 2. however Scarlett was
determined to film as much as possible
and trained for four hours a day for
eight weeks to be able to include parts
that were all her but it wasn't without
some hesitancy from the actress when I
first saw the sequence that they wanted
me to do and it was completed and
choreographed I just thought to myself
oh my God how am I gonna do this to keep
her safe she was attached to a harness a
lot of the time in the end having her
included in the scene added even more
realism to everything
years I've been trying to one thing get
to read
special effects were helping out black
widow right until the very end her trip
to vormir with Hawkeye might be one of
the most VFX heavy scenes she was a part
of this Soulful Adventure was filmed in
front of a large blue screen with the
cliff Edge being a platform that was
constructed in the studio a harness and
wire were used for the final moments of
black widow's story excuse us while we
cry for a second
plant like some debris is coming down
you know what I mean like you know you
could feel the blast
this Bucky car chase scene didn't look
anything like the extravagant Final Cut
we saw unfold on our screen Bucky's
actor Sebastian Stan wasn't even present
for this part of the filming Scarlett
and Chris Evans filmed at a standstill
in a studio car in front of a green
screen what makes the hole behind the
scenes moment even more lackluster is
that they also filmed without sound
effects they instead took directions on
where to look and where to shoot from
the director
the scene where Widow takes on Bucky
single-handedly is another moment that
looks completely different without the
Marvel movie Magic scarlet and Sebastian
performed this scene themselves but it
wasn't without some added safety and
effects Scarlett was attached to a
harness and a wire so that she could
keep her balance on Sebastian's shoulder
and then safely get pushed off like the
car chase scene all of the action and
sound effects in the Final Cut weren't
present while they were filming
payload secure thanks Sam don't thank me
I'm not thinking that thing
despite her dedication to stunts and
fight training in the past this moment
was just a little too high caliber and
dangerous for Scarlett to attempt this
means she was nowhere in sight for the
filming of this sequence it was shot
with stunt doubles all around according
to the filmmakers this helped the scene
turn out more realistic instead of
having to film multiple Cuts with shots
of scarlet intertwined
why you pulled this off I remember a
time when that seemed pretty Impossible
Too
before Black Widow and Hulk kindled
their little romance things were pretty
rough rough as in he chased her down
while destroying everything in his path
however for the filming of scenes like
this Scarlett would film with a green
screen behind her oh thank God so they'd
be able to add the Hulk in later
digitally the explosions we see in the
behind the scenes were controlled
pyrotechnics meant to imitate Hulk's
destruction
remember the huge boat featured in the
opening scenes of Winter Soldier
completely VFX check out this wild
breakdown for filming Scarlett Chris and
the rest of the cast actually just shot
in a studio surrounded by a massive
green screen Scarlett still came flying
in but she was all decked out in a
harness for safety and instead of
falling from a plane it was just from
her place a couple of feet in the air
I'm gonna get a view like this we all
know that Marvel didn't actually destroy
New York City for this battle but we
also didn't expect it to be filmed the
way it was the moment that included
Black Widow was shot entirely in studio
with the actors surrounded by a
ginormous green screen the rubble of New
York was added in with VFX later apart
from a few props like the classic New
York taxis Scarlett also had some help
from her stunt team to execute all of
the fight sequences she had
hasn't been to space
besides the actual actors there wasn't
much that was there during the filming
of black widow's first adventure to
space and even then Bradley Cooper
wasn't sitting in the pilot seat in
place of his character rocket rocket
along with the entire spaceship and
Captain Marvel's suit were added in
using computerized special effects if
you look closely you can see the motion
capture dots that Brie Larson had to
wear in this scene
this earth-shattering or should we say
Earth blipping battle in Infinity war
was filmed on location but they needed
multiple blue screens to transform an
ordinary field into the Battlegrounds we
saw in the Final Cut they even have blue
screen platforms to add Dimension and
help the actors by adding some realism
to it all with Black Widow on the front
lines of the war she was in the midst of
all the special effects like the wakanda
shields that were non-existent behind
the scenes filming these moments took a
lot of imagination on the actors and
directors part
Mark Ruffalo hasn't been shy about how
embarrassed he was to have to wear a
full motion capture suit while filming
amongst the other Avengers I've seen
worse but during this brainstorming sesh
it definitely helped out Scarlett having
Mark act out the scene instead of just
digitally adding in Hulk afterward
allowed Scarlett to carry out a proper
conversation instead of her having to
rely on imagination
far from home wouldn't be the same movie
without its incredible special effects
everything from touching up Spidey suits
to creating the Elementals required
multiple companies hundreds of people
and hours of work so we'll spend this
video breaking down their additions to
the film and just how incomplete it
would look without them in every
interview so when I wear the bubble hat
I'm like
no you didn't
far from home's most memorable scene has
got to be the intense illusion battle
the big Midway fight sequence of the
film frame store the company in charge
of the sequence was given an unusual
amount of freedom to create the scene
they weren't given a set script to
follow instead they were given the
creative freedom to come up with the
concepts for the illusions at the same
time they were animating and adding
effects to the shots this gave them the
unique opportunity to provide direction
for the onset production team for
example with this shot where MJ is
attacked by Mysterio frame store blocked
out the animation ahead of time with a
cgmj complete with precise lighting from
the Moon and lights of the Eiffel Tower
this rendered footage was passed along
to the set production who were able to
recreate the exact lighting frame store
needed for the shot this allowed them to
slip Zendaya's performance into the
final product looking absolutely perfect
by the way the construction site where
the battle takes place 100
CG frames store created the entire
building model adding Tom Holland's
mocap footage on top they used a mocap
suit instead of filming Tom and costume
to save time on set all of those reality
bending Illusions would have meant way
too many costume changes for just one
sequence that nightmare inducing zombie
Iron Man utilized mocap as well frame
store went through several designs for
the undead hero finding the right
balance to be horrifying without showing
anything too gruesome the final product
finds a good middle ground resembling a
mummy beneath the broken bits of
machinery
Marvel moviegoers are no stranger to the
incredible Holograms of this Cinematic
Universe which means the VFX teams have
to keep their designs consistent with
the Marvel style while putting in a few
new twists to keep the visuals from
getting stale for long time fans for
this scene where Mysterio was introduced
as Quentin Beck and explains the
elemental attacks filming was done using
a special light box table Rising Sun
Pictures had to not only design and
place the Holograms in the scene but
adjust the lighting and colors depending
on which Holograms were showing to make
them look like they were really in the
room with the actors the work had to be
done in layers sometimes completely
removing the lighting from onset the
lighting in the raw footage lacks the
subtle colors reflecting from the
Holograms that don't just make the scene
look pretty but create an atmosphere to
complement the actor's performances
[Music]
sometimes an actor's job boils down to
fighting invisible monsters on set the
scene with the water Elemental battle
was filmed on set with Recreations of
buildings from Venice on top of a huge
pool of water and blue screens as
backdrops while the scene utilized a ton
of CG most of the stunts were
accomplished by Tom and his stunt
doubles Luke Scott and Greg Townley
VFX not only hit the wires required to
help Tom jump from pole to pole and
Vault onto the Rialto Bridge but filled
in the backgrounds of Venice and of
course brought the water Elemental to
life there were no rigs or dummies used
for the monster which means the actors
had to rely on their imaginations to
really sell their performances all of
that water they were drenched with was
real though and very cold
similar techniques were used for filming
the scenes in London while portions of
the scenes set on Tower Bridge were
filmed on location they also filmed
using set pieces such as the tour bus in
front of green screens the shots
littered with rubble and broken down
cars were set pieces in front of green
screens too for wide shots imageworks
built a complete 3D model of tower
bridge this model was also used for
filming all the destruction that took
place during the climactic final battle
during all this action we see tons of
drones in various states of Despair
imageworks was able to create all of
these broken Bots by altering their
original models the drones were
constructed out of various individual
pieces all coming together to form a
single machine like the water Elemental
the drones didn't use any object on set
as stand-ins to help the actors
visualize the scene here's what Peter's
final confrontation with Beck really
looked like on set
believe it or not this scene set in a
vibrant field of tulips was filmed in an
empty grass slot in the UK the Jets and
all the flowers were CG image engine had
to simulate an entire field of tulips
with natural wind as well as the jet
Landing over 2 million tulips were
simulated in this scene there were eight
colors and eight different tulips
created for each color in order to
render all of them efficiently they used
a method called pre-caching where
software will download data ahead of
time in anticipation of its use that way
the computers weren't forced to simulate
2 million flowers at the same time
stripped of CGI this scene is just Tom
Holland and John Favreau standing in
some grass
did you know imageworks did VFX for all
the previous Spider-Man movies that's
right they provided effects for the
original trilogy and The Amazing
Spider-Man producers were actually
reluctant to go to them again for the
MCU installments since they wanted to
give the third iteration of the hero a
fresh new look that was until they saw
this test footage imageworks whipped up
to prove that they were up to the task
that's not Tom Holland in costume that's
completely CG the 3D model looked and
moved so convincingly that even Tom
Holland himself was fooled to innovate
on their previous work they focused on
making MCU Spider-Man the most realistic
one yet they did this by studying
imperfections in Tom's movements from
unused takes and incorporating them into
the animated Spider-Man moments of
hesitation or getting caught off balance
helped make the CG Spidey feel far more
grounded in reality than any of the
previous films while some of spidey's
suits are completely computer generated
and require a mocap suit even the
costumes on set require digital tweaking
here and there it can be as simple as
removing wrinkles to keep the suit
looking smooth or adding wear and tear
from the intense action sequences
following in Tony Stark's footsteps
Peter enters the workshop in the back of
the jet to build his own suit for the
first time since he ran around Queens in
sweats while the shots of Peter entering
are all CG there was also a physical set
for the workshop after filming Tom on
set the Holograms were added in post
with VFX image engine had to create an
exact replica of the set in order to
accurately layer the Holograms and
moving Machinery over the real footage
bringing the workshop to life in the
final product this scene isn't just an
important character moment for Peter but
a chance for the audience to see what
goes into building a stark Tech Spidey
suit image engine had to decide what the
individual elements of the suit would
look like ultimately breaking it down
into three layers for the construction
process there is a white wet fiber layer
a layer of black and red fabric
detailing and a layer for hard surfaces
such as the eyepieces and chest patches
the company in charge of VFX for the
final battle in London image Works kept
these detail feels consistent when
adding battle damage to the suit if we
look at his suit closely during his
emotional reunion with MJ we can see
patches of white material where the suit
sustained damage
behind the CGI of Venom there are stunts
practical effects and a ton of
impressive acting Venom is a really
visually exciting movie to watch
especially because of the wild and
shocking transformation we see Eddie
undergo the complex villain is brought
to life thanks to some truly remarkable
CGI behind the scenes is just as
action-packed as the final cut of these
films
Venom 2 definitely doesn't hold back on
the wild action and impressive CGI work
these tendrils have a total life of
their own in this shot but behind the
scenes the Carnage arm grab looks pretty
different
instead of real tendrils wires and
harnesses did the heavy lifting to make
sure the camera is captured what they
needed
the restricted spin around while being
held by wires looks far from comfortable
to deal with but it was well worth it
considering just how epic the final
result looks
while Tom Hardy gives a great
performance the shape-shifting
transformation we see on screen from man
to super villain is all thanks to
painstakingly detailed CGI work the VFX
team actually created animations for
every single frame we see while it took
a lot of time and expertise it was the
best way to make sure the transformation
looked as slick and real as it does
every layer of the detailed animation
images contributes to making Venom's
interactions with people and the world
looked so convincing
one of the coolest scenes in the first
Venom takes to the streets with this
massive mess of black tendrils moving
from flat on the ground to a powerful
stance
while his movements look Flawless in the
Final Cut behind the scenes was a very
different story as the actors were hard
at work to perfect choreography to
properly map out the movements the CGI
team needed the best footage to work
with to bring Venom to the screen in
such a central and Powerful way in the
end they definitely were not
disappointed
the second Venom film features a pretty
massive leap onto the hood of a car
that's made to look like an effortless
Motion in post-production but as we can
see behind the scenes a lot of prep had
to be done and safety measures had to be
considered for this superhuman moment
seeing just how intense the stunt is
without CGI is a great example of how
much acting the performers need to do to
appear as though these daunting tasks
are totally effortless
Venom Let There Be Carnage is filled
with plenty of shooting scenes which of
course are no match for the creature the
drama of it all is still as present
without CGI considering the high stakes
and loud noises all the flashes of light
and details to support the storytelling
are courtesy of added effects since they
were just shooting blanks on the set
the living room sequence in the first
Venom film is one of the most intense
battles in part because of the power
imbalance one versus three hardly seems
fair except for when the one actually
turns out to be pretty fine on his own
thanks to the power of Venom the CGI in
this scene is key for showing the
surprising and Powerful transformation
Tom Hardy goes through a whole lot of
stage combat and practical effects
contributed to executing the battle so
well
as he slowly discovers the sheer amount
of power he has Tom Hardy looks a bit
crazy staring down at his fist as if it
were a monster and to be fair with the
CGI monstrous is a pretty good
descriptor for what we end up seeing
part of what makes the CGI so effective
is the fact that Hardy performed each of
these scenes with 100 commitment
especially when he was embodying Venom
the motorcycle chase scene is one of the
most complicated sequences shot for the
first film and an epic point of action
while the scene itself only lasts a few
minutes before filming even commenced
planning happened for months to make
sure it could all be carried out
efficiently while making sure the Epic
footage was still captured what's even
crazier is that the whole Chase was
actually filmed and CGI was what managed
to weave the whole scene together
seamlessly and with impressive Detail no
less
stunt doubles took over for the actual
riding on the streets Robbie Madison and
Joe Dryden performed legendary motorbike
stunts considering all the planning it's
no surprise about 40 cars ended up being
used and inevitably destroyed over the
course of filming while CGI did Amp up
the look of this nosedive through Flames
stunt performer Dryden really did whip
Through Fire to make sure the team had
the best shot they could get to be
perfected of course with special effects
we get to see the Venom tendrils in full
force when they bring Hardy's character
to safety well as safe as someone can be
whipping through the city on a
motorcycle filming in studio saw the
actor maneuvered by a harness to move
from floating in the air to regaining
control but the moment CGI came into
play was when the scene really came to
life
Robbie Madison looked dangerous straight
in the face when he was preparing for
the huge jump on the famously steep
bullet Hill this was actually the
performer's very first jump in America
and was it ever a cool one since the
team was limited in how many times the
stunt could be performed they needed CGI
to make sure the scene looked good in
the movie after three stunt jumps
Madison was able to really hear the
sounds of the cars crashing in the
intensity of the whole experience hit
him the effects added in post made the
jump look even more legendary
for the wicked motorcycle sandwich the
performers were in real cars and Hardy
was actually on top of a motorcycle but
the whole scene was filmed while the
vehicles were stationary filming with a
blue screen behind them Hardy had some
good opportunities to really perform
well on the motorbike and all the while
not having to worry about his own safety
the CGI fills in the blank adding the
scenery and effects to amplify the
intensity of this moment
this motorcycle slide is nothing short
of impressive the two weeks spent to
create a specially designed metal plate
for the motorcycle to attach to in order
to safely whip around with such speed
was well worth the effort the experience
of filming was pretty wild and the final
result adds a really cool unexpected
moment to the whole sequence
the visual details of Venom really
complete the masterpiece
this apartment fight was pretty wicked
and included the vicious weight throwing
move luckily the actors weren't in any
actual danger since there weren't any
real weights on the set CGI isn't just
used for big explosions and out of this
world creatures sometimes generating
images for more typical or practical
effects is what's needed with major
throws come a whole lot of wires and
harnesses while in the first movie we
see exactly what outer Force throws him
around behind the scenes it almost looks
a bit more like magic since Hardy was
hooked up to wires and harnesses making
sure the tricky stunts could be filmed
safely it looks incredible in rehearsal
so it's no surprise that the final
product is a gem as well slamming into
the wall over and over again can't have
been the most comfortable experience for
the actor though
there were a fair number of window jumps
in the first Venom film some simple
leaps from inside a corridor shattering
glass in the midst and in other cases
epic leaps through the air in both cases
CGI played a key role filling in the
scenery and making performers look like
they're really soaring especially when
it came to all the Venom detailing
25 million per episode and over 2
496 shots with visual effects in the
series how did wandavision do it the
series shows an array of genres from
very decades to drama to Total slapstick
comedy so what did that mean behind the
scenes what were the secrets behind the
magic we'll be covering how the
production brought magic to the screen
and what it was really like for the
performers experiencing it it's been
really fun and different however if you
haven't watched the whole series yet
approach with caution
yes
Avengers end game had 2
496 shots with visual effects and Paul
Bettany AKA Vision has confirmed that
one division had even more how is this
even possible considering how extensive
the effects are for the action-packed
film
well the movie runs just over three
hours whereas the total running time of
all the One Division episodes is a bit
over five and a half hours not to
mention multiple decades in this
fantastic transformation from a
grayscale world to color
at the end of the day a greater variety
and amount of VFX were needed to suit
the vision of the show we should also
mention that there were a whopping 10
different effects companies that
contributed to One Division five and a
half hours of content 10 VFX companies
and about
225 million dollars spent on the entire
series
yeah we can see how over 2500 VFX shots
make sense I'll give you the role you
chose as the series continued we got to
see more and more of the Marvel magic
that we're used to and they didn't shy
away from it when Wanda was in the Town
Square surrounded by the towns people of
Westview watching this scene without all
the effects and Wanda's Red Power
blasting through the hex is definitely
different but the sheer scale of it all
is still really impressive then of
course we all got to Revel in the power
of the Scarlet Witch naturally they
couldn't really have glowing red
surrounding her entirely but this green
screen did the trick Olson's delicate
and Powerful hand motions really do
their job in making this magic look real
add the glowing eyes and she is set
Olson is no stranger to wirework and
thank goodness because she had plenty of
it in one division she looks so calm
cool and collected as she descends down
into the square here I don't understand
this power and how about those epic
battle scenes Olson said that this may
actually be the first time Marvel had a
full battle sequence taking place
entirely in the air take note of how
many wires there are all over these
shots the rigging is definitely no small
task
thank goodness CGI is able to edit out
all the tricks of the trade used to make
the magic though not everything needed a
highly technical VFX
adding some of this magic was as simple
as well
cue the giant fans for Agatha it may
have been her first time in the MCU and
Defying Gravity but she looks like she's
totally in her element here as we can
see she wasn't holding back one bit and
seemed to really Revel in the magic of
it all how about these tense moments
where the actors appeared to Simply Be
levitating without all the wild movement
and soaring through the air
well as we can see here Olson was
essentially placed in a concoction of
wires to hold her up and floating in
Agatha's chamber it doesn't look too
comfortable but the final result well it
speaks for itself let's let Agnes give
it a try
for a human playing a synthazoid betny
does an incredible job as Vision however
credit has to be given to the VFX team
who did an incredible job at using CGI
for his face as well yes he spends hours
in the makeup chair and gets a whole lot
of Prosthetics done but to really bring
the vision of vision to life a team
effort is needed the acting emotion and
heart that's all betany but his face is
often cgied and augmented with effects
his ears are really the main part cgi'd
out of the shot as we can see here
notice how detailed each layer that is
added is each line on his head every
Ridge and texture is added to really
perfect the look let's also take a
minute to acknowledge how flawlessly he
moves when he's flying have you ever
seen a more graceful sweep and then of
course we all got to experience double
vision not too shabby I wish to
understand it
Tiana Paris actually had no idea that
she was auditioning to play Monica Rambo
and when she found out well let's just
say she was thrilled so thrilled she
even nearly tested her superpowers on
the spot practically tried to jump off a
set of stairs because I thought I could
fly I was so excited luckily she waited
until she was on set to try to find
gravity
though flying isn't nearly as impressive
as what her character actually went
through remember when Wanda blasted her
out of the hex well fortunately Paris
didn't have to bear the brunt of Wanda's
upset instead it was a three-dimensional
figure based on Paris that was computer
generated and then added to the shots
and after VFX
though the intense rejection wasn't
quite enough to keep her out of the hex
and mesmerized us with the incredible
transition through static and memory
what were those digital Graphics
inspired by exactly anyway not to worry
we'll be getting to that soon
the hex is probably one of the most
powerful forces we've ever seen at play
in the MCU we were majorly impressed by
the fact that the team managed to
augment the invisible barriers so
intricately this of course took loads of
CGI
the main idea behind the visuals of the
hex was fairly obvious for the team
television what else could suit the show
better
the waves and Graphics that we see used
here reflect what magnetization looked
like across a screen what pixelation
looked like when super zoomed into
old-fashioned TVs as well as the Thin
lines often seen on those old TVs it was
all a reflection of the evolution of
Television technology
everything might look fake in the TV but
everything in there is real turning the
sword base into a circus well let's just
call it a very apt metaphor
check out what this setting looked like
before and after the CGI
accomplishing this transformation
actually wasn't too difficult according
to the VFX Specialists it was as simple
as filming both settings and then using
CGI to augment each one
of the best compliments of VFX or CGI
person can receive is that people had no
idea that some of what's seen on screen
is actually created by computers one of
the more subtle and surprising CGI
touches was the stage found in the Town
Square at first glance we thought this
gazebo-like building was the same one
used by wand and vision when they
perform in the talent show but seeing
the slightly different looking structure
in this later episode we realize it's
not any type of building at all but a
blue screen this is one of those
instances where we really had to see it
to believe it a very small detail but it
proves to us just how much magic there
is who knew this seemingly simple frame
would be one of the over 2500 with added
effects now abracadabra
it wasn't all too serious on set though
the cast definitely had their fair share
of fun especially with so many key
players like Tiana Paris Deborah Jo Rupp
and Catherine Hahn joining the MCU for
the very first time we just love how
enthusiastic Rupp was about having her
body scanned on for CGI
honestly we 'd probably be just as
excited Han was enjoying herself so much
that she even made some entrances way
earlier than she needed to it's okay
though we wanted all the Agatha we could
get
but it wasn't just the newbies who had a
wild time Olson herself started to push
it in the episode that she goes through
an entire pregnancy in a day and went a
bit too over the top granted one his
hormones were going wild at that point
or maybe it had something to do with
that wig
with Loki there is no denying the
magnetic appeal of Loki Tom hiddleston's
incredible performance gets most of the
credit but even he needs help bringing
the trickster God to life on film to
celebrate Loki getting his very own
series we're giving you a look at some
behind the scenes magic of how Marvel
brings the god of Mischief to the screen
in all his glory Loki is still working
on that I think for this scene from Thor
the Dark World the first thing they
filmed was Tom Hiddleston doing an
impression of Captain America as Loki
complete with Cap's costume there wasn't
a technical reason for this apparently
Tom just really wanted to wear the
costume it's not gonna be you though
we're going to get Chris to shoot it
when he's on set and we're gonna he said
no no this is my one chance to wear a
Captain America's suit later Evans was
shown the footage and did his best to
min Tom's performance rep acing it in
the final product he it's him doing an
impression of me doing an impression of
him
and it's brilliant a good villain needs
a grand entrance and Loki certainly
doesn't disappoint Loki's entrance in
the first Avengers movie is a memorable
one thanks in no small part to the VFX
team even without the final polish and
the wires still in sight this shot of
Tom performing this stunt is just as
impressive as the finished shot from the
movie where Loki leaps through the air
and takes down a shield agent always try
and enjoy myself to I'd be having the
best time
speaking of dramatic entrances this
scene from the first episode of Loki
where he's being processed by the TVA
was achieved with a real trapdoor and
Tom Hiddleston on wires he was hooked up
to a rig to achieve a controlled drop
ensuring his safety as they filmed the
stunt luckily Tom already has a lot of
experience doing wire work since Loki
always seems to be getting tossed around
just me jumping into
inches in the set creating that iconic
scene where Loki gets Hulk smashed was
tricky you can't exactly do that with
stunt work to pull this off Tom had a
wire attached to his ankle with a mat on
the floor to catch him and three of the
strongest stunt guys holding the wire at
the other end they waited to interrupt
his villainous monologue and yanked hard
pulling Tom out of frame and down onto
the mat the rest was done with hard work
from the special effects Department the
experience of being yanked out of frame
was one I will not forget in a hurry
Loki and Thor's banter in this scene
from Thor the Dark World where they
break out of Asgard is Unforgettable as
well as a brilliant mix of practical and
special effects Chris and Tom filmed
this scene on a set of the ship's
interior with special effects creating
the holographic interfaces and adjusting
the lighting accordingly while Thor
practically throws Loki out the door
Chris gives Tom a light shove who then
has to throw himself out of the door
onto a mat below I mention I love my
scenes with Chris in every film there's
a two-handed where we kind of touch on
this Odin's emotional departure in Thor
Ragnarok took place on a beautiful
Scenic Cliffside that doesn't actually
exist these scenes were filmed in a
grassy field with the future locations
of new Asgard being entirely built
around them using CGI another surprising
use of digital effects in this scene is
Odin's eye patch which was changed in
post from the plain black eye patch
Anthony Hopkins wore while filming yeah
dead easy well it's a trick dramatic
entrances probably run in the family
because as soon as hella arrives on the
scene you know she means business Thor
and Loki immediately know she's going to
be trouble and suit up to get this
magical costume change Chris and Tom
were filmed entering in both costumes
the footage was spliced together and the
effects team created Thor's lightning
and Loki's signature green Shimmer of
magic to create a transition between
these changes putting them together for
one seamless shot look he was a bad guy
well look he was a misunderstood guy we
love seeing the Odin Sons work together
like when they teamed up in the dark
world using Loki's illusion magic they
fooled malekith into believing Loki had
betrayed Thor going as far as pretending
to cut off Thor's hand and give up Jane
Foster it's very accurate in this shot
Loki literally kicks Thor while he's
down sending him rolling on set it was
Hiddleston delivering a kick that didn't
connect and Hemsworth was pulled away
using wires he never was torturous at
all so I'm incredibly proud of this
while there were parts of Thor and
Loki's confrontation with malakith that
were filmed on location in Iceland
taking advantage of some Barren volcanic
Landscapes the more effects heavy shots
were filmed on a green screen set this
behind the scenes footage really gives
you an appreciation for the amount of
Faith actors have to put into their
directors and their special effects team
there's an art to the physicality of
performances with invisible elements
like CGI magic and Tom pulls it off
beautifully while it may look silly on
set the final product was anything but
it can be surprising exactly which
elements of a scene are created using
CGI like Loki's chains in The Avengers
yeah for whatever reason those were CGI
not part of Tom's costume like they were
for Thor the Dark World Loki's
restraints and muzzle add a lot of
context to these shots so the behind the
scenes footage of the closing scene
looks pretty different without them
props to Tom for being able to
convincingly move like someone in Chains
even limiting how much he moved his
mouth and jaw I think well there was
always going to be an unanswered
question of what on Earth happened
getting Hulk smashed became an odinson
tradition in Thor Ragnarok when Thor
faced off against Hulk in the arena Loki
clearly still holding on to some baggage
from his fight with Hulk is thrilled to
see Thor get the same treatment of
course Tom didn't actually have a
spectacular fight to react to you would
never guess that the only thing he's
really looking at is a room full of
cameras and crew
in the first Avengers movie Thanos uses
one of his followers referred to as the
other to keep an eye on Loki and monitor
his progress conquering Earth the Final
Cut only kept one of their conversations
in with some horrific implications that
Loki was being threatened with torture
but there were several more exchanges
between the two that got left out these
deleted scenes are unfinished but give
us an idea of what the raw filming
process looked like while the other
himself was achieved with practical
effects played by Alexis denisov in
sculpts and makeup the alien world he
hangs out in when speaking to Loki was
mostly blue screen they followed me into
some interesting Corners in the first
Thor movie we meet the frost Giants and
later learned that Loki was originally
the son of their King not Odin most of
the frost Giants or yotens as they're
also called were filmed using practical
effects the actors would spend hours
having sculpts and makeup applied to
them to achieve just the right look but
this lengthy process wouldn't have been
practical for Tom's brief scenes in
Loki's yotun skin instead his red eyes
and blue skin were added in post as soon
as I look in the mirror after I've been
through it's like wow ever wonder why
Loki's helmet has changed so many times
since the first Thor movie even putting
on the helmet was more complicated than
you think since Tom couldn't just pull
it on over his head the final product
used in Thor actually had to come apart
in two pieces which would be snapped
together to encase Tom's head according
to him it was like having his brain
cooked all of his body heat would build
up under the helmet driving him a bit
mad which he says he used to fuel his
performance that's probably why we see a
lot less of it in the Avengers and it
didn't return until Thor Ragnarok with a
more minimalist redesign you have to be
careful what you let in in because you
can know that can sort of spill into
what you're doing last but not least is
this deleted scene from Thor it's a fun
character moment where Loki gets to
cause some Mischief after being mocked
and laughed at Loki gets even by turning
a goblet of wine into snakes the effects
are unfinished and there's even some
shots where lighting rigs are still
visible props to this extra who had to
convincingly react to a magical prank
that wasn't actually happening we just
look at it as creatives and say look at
all of these things we could play with
when you're working on movies as crazy
as Venom and its recent sequel of course
you're dealing with a whole lot of CGI
but did you know there are tricks to
making it look so sexy and smooth let's
take a look behind the VFX curtain at
Let There Be Carnage why do I even talk
to you guys everyone else that story
kills that's the whole story yes
please
now that Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock and the
Symbiote are more in sync and working as
Venom this film freed up Tom Hardy to
really go nuts new director Andy Circus
wanted to give the actor the freedom to
move around without having to worry
about putting a man in a suit be it
mocap or Monster on screen since Venom
is coming out of Hardy it made more
sense to have him skip the mocap and
layer the Monstrous side of Venom right
over the actor according to Circus I've
spent a considerable amount of my life
playing a character with two sides to
his personality I knew that this film
would be about how to free up Tom to
imagine Venom's presence we knew it
would not be helpful for him to act
opposite a man in a suit because Venom
is a symbiote coming out of him we
wanted to give Tom the freedom in his
process to give the performance he
wanted Hardy has also weighed in on this
decision saying in an interview for
total film that the decision to not
worry about mocap was an easy one given
the difference in height between himself
and Venom as well as the extreme
flexibility of the creature's face and
limbs saying so the mocap treatment went
out the window pretty quickly facially
your eyes and teeth and tongue are not
going to match with this and you need a
seven foot tall basketball player in a
Liker suit for the physical shots how do
we you know move this around not just
necessarily with uh animation or CGI or
motion capture but as an actor
you've got to be willing to look a
little nuts when you're pretending to be
a seven foot tall monster who eats
people's heads since the production
chose to have Hardy physically on set
and doing stunt work for many of the
film's action sequences the actor had to
dig deep into his history of playing
Tufts and Heavies as well as his more
reactive animalistic performances like
Max rokatansky in Mad Max Fury Road and
James Keziah Delaney in taboo just in
case you know it's successful which you
hope it is and you put everything into
it
one of the biggest changes going into
Venom 2 was the decision to replace
departing director Reuben Fleischer with
Andy Circus having made a name for
himself working with WETA to bring
characters like Gollum King Kong and the
Planet of the Apes as Caesar to life the
guy is still the Undisputed king of
detailed motion capture performances
even though the film shies away from
motion capture he was still an excellent
voice to have on set as he could help to
block out scenes and accommodate for the
height differences between his actors
and the creatures they were portraying
in fact circus received a call to
consult on the film though he didn't
know it at the time Tom Hardy gave
circus a call and said Andy I'm going to
be doing this character and it's going
to be a digital character and I wondered
if I could come down to the Imaginarium
which is a performance captor studio in
the UK but then circus didn't hear from
him again for a while and it wasn't
until Venom came out that he realized
Hardy was talking about Venom he really
had to act in this movie he really is a
big a big character
foreign
things about watching the new Venom is
checking out Woody Harrelson as Cletus
Cassidy as Cassidy Harrelson is taking
huge wild swings to portray the serial
killer imbuing him with a larger than
life personality as he tears his way
through San Francisco surfs on cars and
generally looks like he's having a blast
the whole time this didn't feel like I
was free enough to be more creative
here's an incredible bit of stunt work
for you that motorcycle stunt where
Eddie goes flying during a massive jump
well it turns out that it was really
mostly him the production set up the
jump and then put both the bike and
Hardy on wires moving them together and
apart on a green screen and then adding
the CGI tendrils later Windows get
smashed and motorbikes and all kinds of
things that happen
one of the things that the sequel really
amps up from the first film is the
incredible dysfunctional domestic
relationship between Eddie and the
Symbiote treating them more like an old
married couple than a crime-fighting Duo
this is on Full glorious display during
the scene set in Eddie's apartment where
the effects team connected props
furniture and sometimes whole actors to
cables so that the objects were moving
through a physical space and could be
embellished with Venom's many CGI
tendrils later on and yes that includes
Sonny and Cher Eddie and Venom's pet
chickens who were played by live animals
there's an enormous amount of humor to
be had out of this entire scene
here's something that's sure to give you
flashbacks to playing racing games when
you were little apparently Tom Hardy has
a habit on set of making his own sound
effect when he was getting hit or
throwing punches and even as he was
getting his nose broken by the Symbiote
something that puts in in the grand
tradition of actors who can't stop
making sounds on set like Harrison Ford
in the original Star Wars I pick orders
from just one person me
sometimes there's not a whole lot to do
but fake an entire scene such as this
one where Cletus Cassidy transforms
fully into Carnage background locations
props the monster even Cassidy himself
were all rendered digitally giving us a
cool and gnarly look at the musculature
of a symbiote suit when it puts itself
together
foreign
fate and timing are against you and you
have to make certain concessions to the
movie gods for example this scene with
Cassidy in the car was originally
supposed to be filmed as a larger stunt
on location except well a little movie
called The Matrix resurrections was
shooting in town at the same time and
they got the location first instead the
scene with the suspended car was rigged
against blue screens and large
projection screens to recreate the city
skyline you know that's cool because I I
sure enjoyed playing them and I I'm glad
I got to do this
there seems to be one little trick to
shooting an animation scene in a Venom
movie all you do is attach a string or a
suspension harness to literally
everything in the shot and then you pull
and wiggle everything around like these
poor stunt guys in the scene were
Carnage and Cassidy escape from prison
as I walked around I felt like the king
of course it wouldn't be a movie
released in 2021 if we didn't talk about
a little bit of pandemic delay shooting
on the film finished early on but due to
release delays Andy Circus and his team
were blessed with a ton of extra time to
tweak the edit of the film and more
closely oversee the CGI work
it takes a lot to create truly
convincing CGI back in the days of black
and white films production designers had
to work carefully to pick outlandish
colors that would still pop together and
be distinguishable when reduced to a
grayscale but Venom 2 is a testament to
the fact you still need to be careful to
create the illusion of this symbiote goo
actually coming out of the actors and
seeping through their clothes picking
placement and really reactive colors was
a must
finally here's a little bit of Revenge
for you there are several large night
scenes in venom 2 where there are a
bunch of helicopters flying around in
the background they don't really impact
anything but they add a certain scope to
the scene so you might be forgiven for
thinking that they're CGI not true
though they're actually helicopters that
were flying around a nearby location for
the shoot of you guessed it the Matrix
resurrections so sweet free helicopters
film of this scale this piece of grand
entertainment Blockbuster material with
a predominantly Black cast I mean it
just hasn't been done before every
moment Every Beat is mapped out talking
about a month long process just for that
15 seconds stranger things is easily one
of the most terrifying shows on Netflix
we've seen demogorgons mind players and
now we've got factna lurking around
waiting for our Kate Butch CD to skip
have you ever wondered what the show
would look like without the visual
effects bringing these creatures to life
let's get into it okay
special effects
number one
The Duffer Brothers only knew a few
things for certain about the demogorgon
they wanted him to come from another
dimension and have a human body type the
body type was really important to them
because they wanted to be able to put an
actual person inside the costume for
season one shooting purposes
very quickly we realized okay so
practical isn't always going to work in
season four however they brought in
animation the first animation passed
that's when you're seeing what looks
almost like just a gray clay rendering
the first pass is really important
because that's when they can hammer out
the details like how long they want him
to Roar for example after that they get
to the rendering stage that's where the
fun really starts everything they've
shot all the animation and real-life
stunts get to coexist together it's
really exciting when those shots finally
come together and all the elements
number two
the demogorgon is one thing but the
actual fight scenes require a different
approach a good portion of time the
demogorgon is just a guy in a green suit
sometimes he would have a tennis ball at
the top of his head to show us how tall
the demogorgon was in the scene where
Hopper has his major Showdown with the
demogorgon The Duffer Brothers really
wanted to try and do that entire scene
in one shot but unfortunately because of
how dangerous the stunts were they were
not able to do that we didn't want to be
using CG people on top of a CG so we
weren't able to do it all in one shot
they wanted to protect their stunt team
so they did three big stun sequences and
stitched them all together would you
have been able to tell the Americans are
very tricky number three
it takes a lot of work an entire team of
people in fact to make vechna look as
horrifying as he did the actor Jamie
Campbell Bower went through an egregious
eight and a half hour prosthetic
application every time he had to play
vechna one thing they couldn't do with
prosthetics though was remove his nose
on each application day we had a black
nose on Jamie with some little white
marking dots so VFX could remove that in
post VFX also added in those creepy
slithering vines coming out of vechna's
back I'm for you
to join me
number four
speaking of vacna his eight and a half
hour prosthetic seems to pay off because
the cast was typically very frightened
whenever they chewed a scene with him
zachna was pretty much fully practical
effects and made it easier for me so I'm
not like staring at a man in a green
suit Sadie sink also spent a great deal
of her time in a harness rehearsing for
her levitation scene right before her
big showdown in the upside down there's
not a lot that you have to do because
it's genuinely just so scary number five
one thing you might not know about
Steve's journey to Watergate was that it
wasn't even shot in a real light it was
shot in a Convention Center in Atlanta
Georgia Joe Kiri recounts diving into a
40-foot tank specifically Built For This
scene getting to do that sort of stuff
is like true movie magic number six
the insane shootout that destroyed every
inch of the buyer's home was also shot
in one take John Levy the director of
episode 4 was compelled to do it all in
one shot he said it was the most
challenging and most rewarding scene
he's ever directed the whole challenge
with the winner is it requires perfect
synchronicity considering they only had
one choreography session for this scene
it's fair to say they killed it
everybody needed to do their job at a
high high level of near Perfection it's
a doozy number seven
you know that part when fechna's victims
are getting every bone in their body
snapped like a wishbone on Thanksgiving
of course how could you forget it's
quite difficult to watch but
surprisingly not that difficult to
achieve with special effects to break
the fingers it's essentially working
with different layers of a moving hand
within Adobe After Effects for the legs
they utilize a much more practical
approach they need to put their arms
through the pants so they can function
as legs and with the bigger range of
motion of an arm we can now create a
twisting braking movement
Factor
an undead creature of great power
number eight
the unique thing about stranger things
is how they blend practical effects like
makeup and Prosthetics with VFX in every
scene with VFX they also heavily rely on
the makeup team as we stated earlier
Jamie Campbell Bauer worked very closely
with the makeup team so close that he
had his own team of people applying Lube
onto his entire body our last 10-15
minutes should be the four of us
literally getting this product all over
him to make him look really really
glossy number nine
we're all familiar with 11's iconic
nosebleed but have you ever wondered how
they get the blood to flow at the right
time at first corn syrup a lot of it the
only time Millie would get to call
Action on set was when she felt it
dripping from her nose you know my nose
is running with blood so I'm like okay
are we ready it's coming three two
because that didn't always go according
to plan they ended up using CGI blood
for those scenes in later Seasons it's
fun to film but also really stressful
number 10. the character of Victor had a
brutal disfiguring after his encounter
with vechna in reality we can thank the
brilliant prosthetic work of Barry Gower
for Victor's disturbing look the
sculpture of Vicks creel's appliance
which you can see the difference in tone
where the appliance finishes just prior
to Robert's hairline the two-hour
process was so bad for the team because
they were able to reference actual scars
as opposed to something that is
completely fictional
mode
all evil must have a home number 11.
11 is me like 11 is just who I am now it
doesn't take very long for the cast to
transform into their characters but
Millie's transformation into 11 is a
little more involved it takes about an
hour to do my old wig my makeup isn't
that crazy at all so judging by this
math you could create at least eight
Elevens in the time it takes to create
one becna Jamie Campbell Bower we do not
envy you underneath all that molding
clay
number 12. in stranger things the upside
down is just as important as any other
character in the show so how exactly do
they create it a recurring theme we've
seen with The Duffer Brothers is that
they prefer to do things as practical as
they can we realize that in fact the
vision that the brothers had was more
extensive than one can always do
practically when it comes to creating
all of the upside down creatures they
had to call on a team of CGI experts it
starts usually with a sculpture so we
digitally sculpt things so with a
mixture of practical components and a
hard-working visual effects team they
were able to create this stunning world
just beneath our own so now you've seen
it all the blend of real life animation
mounds of Prosthetics and the iconic man
in the green suit the visual effects
team clearly works overtime in Hawkins
have you ever wondered what iconic
Twilight scenes would look like if movie
Magic had an interfere without the help
of CGI many of our favorite franchises
most iconic scenes would look pretty
silly Twilight is no exception with all
the Fantastical fight scenes drastic
aging of characters throughout the films
and many actors seeming to seamlessly
transition from Human to werewolf let's
break down how some of the Twilight
franchise's famous scenes were brought
to life
in Twilight one of the Hallmark traits
of a vampire is their glittering skin
when it catches the sunlight it's like
diamonds ilm the special effects team
also owned by lucasfilm was able to add
in the extra Sparkle on Pattinson's face
in post-production in New Moon Prime
Focus VFX was responsible for making
Edwards Sparkle visual effects
supervisor Eric pascarelli explains the
process there was a very delicate
balance of the elements that make up the
effect we use 3D particle geometry
dispersed over a CG model of Edward's
head to reflect several artificial
environments in order to create the
Sparkles and Rays
one of the most romantic and
exhilarating moments for Bella early on
in the relationship is jumping through
trees with Edward you better hold on
tight spider monkey in the movie it
looks easy enough but sparing no expense
the producers of Twilight didn't want to
only rely on CGI for these moments the
visual effects team led by Richard Kidd
had to install a support rig that was
about 100 feet tall and spanning three
large pine trees it was four pipes that
created the structure like a box and
they snapped together like Lego pieces
kids said the rig wasn't only for
studying the natural pine trees but also
used to hold the winches and pulleys
used to carry the actors and crew up and
down from the trees once the filming was
finished the visual effects team had to
go back and digitally remove the rig
cables and harness used on the actors
which required a lot of meticulous work
on the editor's end
generally considered somber films the
Twilight series offers moments of levity
the vampire baseball scene in the first
Twilight movie is a great example
vampire baseball is just like regular
baseball but a lot cooler to make the
actors seem as if they were practically
flying they were attached to a harness
that would move them around in
correlation to their marks the cast also
had to strut on a grass-covered moving
walkway to give the illusion of a
supernaturally speedy vampire gate
nobody can forget that epic moment when
we got to see Jacob transform from a
teenager to a full-on werewolf while
looking effortless practically graceful
on screen there was a lot of work that
went into each of those Transformations
the giant werewolves were all created
using CGI and actor Taylor Lautner's
already filmed scenes were used for
reference Lautner was hooked up to a
harness to simulate him jumping off into
werewolf form and then a werewolf was
built around that and then added into
the movie in post-production
we all love Bella for her quiet nature
open heart and overall relatability but
we also love her because she's a strong
woman who sticks up for herself we see
in a scene and New Moon a heated
confrontation about Jacob ends in Bella
punching Paul making him turn into his
werewolf form at first glance the scene
looks like a pretty easy one but actress
Kristen Stewart had to rehearse that
punch with a stunt coordinator and then
coordinate the timing and the moves out
with the other actors this scene also
showed the audience another graceful
transformation from Human to werewolf by
Paul
Eclipse has one of the most thrilling
and epic action scenes in the entire
franchise the chase scene with Victoria
to simulate jumping off of rocks the
actors were hooked up to a harness
attached to the ceiling of a filming
Studio where they would have to jump on
green screen Boulders that were just
green Ledges and steps the actors were
also filmed running on what the
production crew called magic carpets
that would make it appear that they were
running a lot faster than they actually
were
a tender moment shared between Bella and
Jacob in werewolf form is right before
the big battle scene against Victoria
and her newborns against the Cullens and
the werewolves in eclipse in the movie
werewolf Jacobs Saddles up to Bella and
she gives him a sweet scratch on the
head which was all edited in
post-production to look like she was
scratching a real werewolf while filming
actor Taylor Lautner was dressed in a
non-reflective bodysuit and hat and he
stood in where his werewolf self would
be in the movie Kristen Stewart went as
far as scratching Taylor's head while
filming werewolf or human in a bodysuit
it's still pretty sweet
the way the production staff were able
to make it seem like actress Mackenzie
Foy was actually riding on the back of
Jacob in werewolf form is pretty
complicated they had Mackenzie sit on a
motion control rig a machine that
resembles a mechanical bull with a
saddle covered in werewolf Jacob's fur
the rig was set against a green screen
and pre-programmed with all the moves to
resemble Jacob running and Mackenzie sat
on it while they filmed her with a wind
machine blowing so it looked like she
was moving fast
the animators at tippet Studio started
by going to the actual lumber yard and
getting footage there then built the
whole scene starting with the dialogue
from the actors from a recording tippet
studios actually had helicopters flown
over the area with cameras so they could
get an aerial view then they created a
storyboard deciding the shots and once
they were approved to move forward they
started working on animating the Wolves
against the real-life lumber yard
backdrop
baby Renesmee was originally meant to be
a to scale animatronic doll but the
producers deemed it too scary to use and
the actors never looked comfortable
acting against it the animatronic
version had full length hair and giant
unnatural looking eyes even for a half
vampire half Human Instead The Producers
decided to use CGI a rubber baby doll
and an actual human baby to create every
aspect of baby Renesmee which has
garnered better but not great reviews
from fans and audiences alike
there were several options on how the
production team could choose to make
Renesmee age at a superhuman rate in
Breaking Dawn Part 2 and they chose to
use Lola visual effects to reimagine
Mackenzie as Renesmee from birth up
until her age at the end of the series
utilizing baby photos of Mackenzie the
effects team was able to create an
accurate chart of what Renesmee would
look like at any age and they used
actual babies as physical stand-ins
while shooting sounds pretty intense but
the payoff was worth it
the Twilight Saga and snow go together
like peanut butter and jelly in fans
minds and it's fitting that the final
battle with the Volturi is beautifully
set with a snow-capped background but
when actually filming the actors and
crew were inside a Production Studio
where there were green screen backdrops
and fake snow grounds the camera crew
rode on a vehicle while the actors had
to run towards or away from it in the
snow
the pregnancy and eventual birth scenes
in the Breaking Dawn movies were one of
the few times we really got to
experience the horror and romance aspect
at its peak in Twilight to make Kristen
Stewart look as emancipated and frail as
she did in the movie she went through
extensive makeup and even face
Prosthetics to really give the full look
also the FX team actually built a
life-size doll of Kristen that they used
when Edward was giving her CPR Kristen's
actual body was underneath the bed with
the dummy on top
the final battle in Eclipse is visually
breathtaking seeing beautiful powerful
people and werewolves run around in a
snow-covered Forest definitely gives
viewers a treat believe it or not the
battle in the snow was filmed inside of
a Production Studio where a full-size
set of the forest was built where they
couldn't use practical effects such as
trees and fake snow a green screen
behind the set was utilized in
post-production to give it that Winter
Wonderland feel
one of the first times Bella and the
audience gets to witness some of
Edward's supernatural abilities are in
the intense action scene where Bella is
almost hit by Tyler's van thankfully
Edward who was across the parking lot
sped to her rescue and stopped the
moving van with his hand leaving a
sizable Dent they were able to make this
happen by replacing the original
passenger side door with a soft molded
door that would easily move under Robert
Pattinson's hand
expecto patronum there's nothing like
escaping to Hogwarts and indulging in
all that the Wizarding World has to
offer but how would the Harry Potter
films look if we stripped away the magic
would Voldemort still be as threatening
would wand duels look as epic it's time
to find out
[Music]
quidditch it's a huge part of Harry
Hogwarts and literally the entire world
of magic it's actually one of the first
parts of the Wizarding World we get to
see come to life but without a green
screen quidditch and broom flying isn't
all it's cut out to be to bring the
magic to life the actors would sit on an
actual broom that was attached to a rig
the rig was pre-programmed with the
movements to make it look like the
actors were fighting a dragon or
catching a golden snitch
look what it's just great
this guy in the race and you'll be great
too the final showdown between Voldemort
and Harry had to be epic it's what the
entire series was leading up to after
all however a lot of movie Magic was
needed to bring out the real magic the
Hogwarts grounds in the background the
magic shooting out of their wands
Voldemort disintegrating into
nothingness we can watch that scene over
and over but let's check out what that
scene looks like without CGI and a green
screen basically two actors pointing
wooden sticks at each other not that
Daniel Radcliffe and Ralph finds aren't
amazing actors though also how weird is
it to see Voldemort with a nose you've
been taught how to do what I presume yes
first we bow to
speaking of the Dark Lord in his nose
Voldemort's soulless appearance was also
thanks to the help of something magical
it's called VFX they use these effects
to not only edit Ralph's entire face
including his snake-like nose but to
also get the Voldemort we see at the
beginning of the Deathly Hallows
remember him soaring above the sky
trying to figure out which of the seven
Harry's was the real one
Harry Potter
is dead
who else thinks that the Goblet of Fire
is the most magical movie of them all
from the Quidditch World Cup to the Yule
Ball there was nothing quite like the
magical Vibes that came with the golden
Trio's fourth year at Hogwarts including
the tri-wizard tournament Hogwarts has
been chosen to host a legendary event in
Harry's first task he has to maneuver
around a dragon and snatch up the golden
egg but without the help of CGI the
scene is almost magicless the dragons
are actually computer generated based on
a scan of a model dragon and we already
know how they brought the broom flying
to life who wants me to open it
you want me to open it Perry's second
task is even more lethal than the first
and surprisingly more magical Daniel
Radcliffe did take a deep dive for the
scene so we really are seeing him
swimming and the guilt he grows thanks
to Neville's gillyweed are also visible
thanks to Prosthetics however everything
else is completely missing without the
help of computers the Great Lake was
actually a water tank with a blue screen
and the grindelos they were all added in
later on Daniel was just given
instruction on where he should turn and
react so it could look magical later on
there are more people in the Black Lake
are there the third and final task is
tragic but still very Supernatural we
see Harry's first Face-Off with
Voldemort in his actual form their magic
collides and in an epic finale Harry
gets to see his past loved ones one more
time as their ghosts help him to escape
back to the safety of Hogwarts
we can linger for a moment to give you
some time but only a moment you
understand however if you take a look at
this video you'll see just how different
this scene would look without its magic
even the maze wasn't actually there
who doesn't wish they could have a Dobby
of their own where would Harry be
without the house elf and even though
creature is a bit more standoffish he
does help out Harry in the seventh film
but we're sad to say that house elves
unfortunately aren't real
who are you Dolby sir Dobby the house
elf in fact during the filming of their
scenes Dobby and creature are actually
just actors in Gray motion suits check
out how bizarre these scenes look before
the Final Cut they would also have
models of the elves on set for reference
don't be sure creature in Diagon Alley
which Dobby thought was curious the
seventh film started off with a bang
seven of them to be exact but just how
would the scene with seven Harry's look
if we broke it down well for starters
there weren't actually seven Daniel
Radcliffe's instead Dan filmed each of
the Harry's Parts separately in front of
a green screen then they were all added
in using effects later on including the
morphing of his face the crew claims
that this was one of the trickiest
scenes to make magical just because of
how closely they had to pay attention in
order for everything to work out
perfectly we did also have to say break
the record for the most number of takes
ever done if there's one thing Harry
Potter is known for it's their moving
images you see them throughout the
movies in places like books newspapers
and in the photos that line the walls of
Hogwarts they even have personalities
but they're not real sorry to pop your
magical bubble but they're actually not
even regular photos blue screens were
put in as a substitute for where the
pictures would go and the gift-like
videos were added on by editors after
the filming was complete Harry and
Buckbeak a match made in heaven okay
maybe that was taking a little too far
but Harry did help save his life we
finally have some good news for you
Buckbeak was technically on set he
existed but he was mechanical they had
to make three different buckbeaks so
they could get him performing different
movements properly then the CGI team
would step in and make him super
lifelike they had to create and edit
every single feather on Buckbeak
Buckbeak now lives in the Harry Potter
Museum take a look at this Fan's video
say hello to buckby
we get quite a few different scenes with
the room of requirement and let's face
it it's probably one of the coolest
things at Hogwarts there was one scene
in the room specifically that really
stands out it happens in the eighth and
final film while Harry is on the search
for ravenclaw's diadem of course Draco
and his minions had to have one last go
at Harry and in turn the room ends up
full of flames and we get to see Harry
on his broom for a final time but if we
Strip This scene down it's a whole lot
of green screen with the actors strapped
into harnesses
foreign
place on fire
if you watched Fantastic Beasts you know
that nagini has a backstory of her own
she's not just Voldemort's pet and
horcrux which means it was only right
they give her some epic magical scenes
in Harry Potter but all the credit for
that really goes to the visual effects
team during filming nagini wasn't there
which probably made the actor's job a
little more difficult when they were
meant to be interacting or looking at
her nevertheless they managed to pull it
off perfectly we might add and gave us
some epic nagini scenes
nagini
dinner
goblins are one of the first creatures
from The Wizarding World that we meet
alongside Harry in his first year but
there's one Goblin that plays an extra
special role in bringing down Voldemort
even if he does betray Harry Ron and
Hermione it's grip hook like Dobby and
creature there was a prosthetic model
made of grip hook but they also covered
Warwick Davis in Prosthetics in order to
bring the mythical creature to our
screens I don't look right I am too good
looking the three dangerous tasks
weren't the only magical things that
surrounded the tri-wizard tournament the
tri-wizard Cup itself took a lot of work
to become magical onset of the film the
actors were surrounding a pretty
ordinary trophy there were no blue
flames or age line that prevented the
Weasley twins from dropping in their
names and during the choosing ceremony
the cup didn't actually spit out the
paper with Harry's name on it in a
dramatic Fury of flames that was all
added in after filming
I don't know
the Whomping Willow was pretty
unforgiving to Harry and Friends during
their time at Hogwarts with its
Relentless branches it definitely took
them on a ride and watching how they
made the tree come to life is another
ride altogether of course A lot of it
was green screen but they actually had a
fake branch that actors like Emma Watson
would hop on to imitate the movements
the behind the scenes of this might not
look magical but it sure does look cool
the streets of free City are very much a
world that feel a little bit like our
own but way better what movie Magic
transformed Ryan Reynolds into dude free
city is more like CGI City nothing in
this world is possible without some
incredible VFX
Ryan Reynolds in this new improved body
originally dude was meant to look
exactly like guy with Ryan Reynolds
pulling double duty as both characters
but instead of taking the time to shoot
Ryan acting twice and buff him up later
in post-production the crew decided to
find a very beefy actor who could
portray him instead Aaron Reed was the
chosen one not true I gained 312 pounds
for this film Reed was shot using motion
capture notice all those dots on his
face and in post-production Lola VFX
stitched Reynold's face onto Reed's body
like a real-life Frankenstein situation
he's spectacular for the fight with dude
the team used wires props and mats to
get the action just right the scene
definitely took some great fight
choreography and an amazing stunt team
to pull it off also many of the iconic
props like the Captain America shield
were filmed with plain looking stand-in
props and then updated later with CGI
lots of stunt performers and VFX were
involved with the fight scene that
happened when guy and Molotov girl head
to the Stash House to retrieve her
stolen code the scene involved spawn
points tons of weapons and video game
fighting styles behind the scenes people
were being thrown onto mats while
attached to wires and performers were
pretending to be hit by numerous
projectiles and weapons to get the
motorcycle slide just right guy's bike
was pulled forward with wires and Ryan
Reynolds stunt double stepped in to do
most of the dangerous stuff it all comes
together to create a perfectly chaotic
scene where players appear out of
nowhere for an all-out brawl and
honestly it looks like a pretty fun
albeit exhausting day to have been on
set was that cool it felt really cool a
lot of the movie's most dangerous scenes
were done as practical stunts with CGI
added later for the complicated
construction site Chase it took a lot of
planning trained stunt performers and
VFX to get things right many of these
injuries like guy's head becoming a
little too friendly with a concrete
pillar are only possible in a video game
and would surely send you to the
hospital or worse in real life to create
this scene of guy falling and landing in
the bubble suit the filmmakers used a
stunt performer on wires positioned
against a green screen for close shots
and a digi-double version of Ryan
Reynolds for the wide shots and extreme
bounces once on the ground Ryan was
really filmed in a prop bubble which was
either really comfortable or really
uncomfortable we're not sure but
someone's gotta ask him and that was the
heartbreaking story of blue shirt guy
real cars were used on the streets of
free City but they had a CGI layover put
on top of them to make them look more
unique video game worthy and futuristic
the movie director Sean Levy said we
want the world of our city filled with
vehicles that aren't just every day we
want them in models and customized
editions and colors that are all kind of
like dialed up reality with the CGI
layover they could smooth and round out
the car's edges add signs of damage you
name it all without actually damaging or
changing the cars the vehicles ended up
looking a little unlike models we have
in real life but close enough to be
recognizable in the real world and cool
enough to be coveted by video game
enthusiasts impressive adding all the
chaos that surrounds the cars during
epic Chase scenes was also incredibly
important to get the free city world to
really feel like a Grand Theft Auto
inspired Universe where there's all
kinds of pandemonium pyrotechnics Sparks
and Mayhem were added to these scenes
while the stunt drivers cruised the
streets so they didn't have to deal with
any real obstacles you can see in this
scene that some cars they hit aren't
really there at all including this
massive pile up the chase scenes got the
action right by filming stunt drivers in
front of green screens they were filmed
with a robotic motion controlled camera
moving on a track to keep things smooth
like when Channing Tatum's character
does a slo-mo 360. it was so hot oh I
know free guy with shot in Boston with a
few reshoots taking place in La while
the Interiors were built on airport
hangars or sound stages but other cities
like Seoul Tokyo Seattle Pittsburgh and
even Christopher Nolan's Gotham City
served as inspiration for how the video
game world would look to get everything
right the team actually created free
City Twice first as live-action footage
with digital editions and again as a
fully CG environment they created
futuristic unique and dilapidated
storefronts by using real buildings and
overlaying them with CGI to turn them
into the unique free City shops that we
see on our screens production designer
Ethan tobman said that they did a ton of
branding and developed two stories of
entire blocks with signage that you'd
never see in the real world different
cameras were used to distinguish between
free City and the real world the video
game scenes were shot with a large
format camera and spherical lenses with
a color palette that was almost animated
while the real life scenes were filmed
in a more down to earth Style with a
more restricted color palette
you're real and I'm what I'm what
you're not when the glasses go on the
world becomes even more different it's
like The Truman Show where the main
character doesn't know what's really
going on until he's given away to see it
so there had to be a pretty big
distinction between guy's reality and
lair's reality to accomplish this
there's another layer of VFX creating
what the game's players see with
director Sean Levy taking advantage of
the fact that he was the creator of that
world within the world these images that
appear all around free City for players
are meant to look even more animated and
interactive than the fantasy city does
to its NPCs the team also used different
camera techniques when guy puts on his
glasses like having it suddenly become
first person and then filming from
behind him as if a video game player is
actually changing their camera
perspective
that's that's not good the street
squeeze scene looks like it could be
right out of a superhero movie which
isn't so surprising considering the
film's VFX supervisor Sven gilberg also
worked on Avengers Infinity war and end
game in this scene there were some real
cards being driven by trained
professionals but for the most part all
the action was compiled together with
some incredible VFX these shots on the
streets closing in the streets crumbling
and cars being flung Every Which Way
were all added by the incredibly
talented people at scanline VFX so don't
worry no stunt drivers were harmed in
the making of This scene the destruction
of free city was also a complicated
scene literally the world can reshape it
required incredible VFX but it also
required the actors to pretend that it
was really being destroyed because in
reality all of that destruction was
accomplished with some epic CGI that had
the city pixelating into a million
pieces scanline VFX was responsible for
the scene which had the world of free
City literally falling out from
underneath its citizens feet for the
Stampede in the city there were some
real actors involved running for their
lives but there were also extra digital
renderings of characters added in later
to fill out the crowd as for guy finally
reaching the life itself Island you
guessed it the green Oasis was entirely
animated this
free City and the people who wear
sunglasses are heroes computer animation
was also used to create these iconic
scenes where players free fall and then
glide into free City the scenes
introduce us to what's really possible
in the Video Game World some of the
characters like this guy coming in like
a flying squirrel are entirely animated
but when characters are shown coming
down in parachutes or getting close to
the ground they're really attached to
wires on a crane the crew had quite the
complicated setup prepared to get all
these falling and flying scenes just
right that was every director's dream
it's just you alone are a big Sound
Stage for three days men with leaf
blowers House of the Dragon has brought
us a world filled with Fantastical
creatures Monumental locations and Vivid
characters but how was this world
brought to life stick around to find out
more about what house of the Dragon
looked like without the VFX
ah well done that was great number one
seriously Hold On Tight hello guys we
are going on to set it's rocking right
let's try to win again House of the
Dragon after Leo Ashton was challenged
with having to ride a dragon at work on
more than one occasion but getting into
this saddle wasn't going to be a pony
ride around the park the first day was
quite hard and the next star came in I
felt so much power and I was like I need
to get this this Dragon moves like a
giant mechanical bull putting together
this scene presented several challenges
including the moment when the Dragon
Goes vertical and Leo's character needs
to hang on from the reins number two
every tournament needs an arena right
and I said really Jim if you've got the
money to build that and he goes yeah
yeah
the tournament took place not in a field
with some flags and a few onlookers
around it but in the depths of the city
surrounded by buildings and a colossal
Arena that reminds us of the real life
Coliseum for this a special structure
was created out of a large Dome and a
half moon shaped section of the Arena
while CGI was part of this most of it
was carefully built in real life number
three you can't CGI a soft Landing for a
stunt performer gravity works and hard
ground is hard when preparing the
grounds for the construction of the
Arena set while much of the scene was
created using CGI some things just
needed to be done for real when working
with horses you need soft ground and
stunt performers seem to like it too you
know what my whole system to hurt
themselves you don't want to stunt men
to hurt themselves that meant before
construction could start on the arena an
area of land had to be heavily modified
leveled and carefully layered with the
right materials in order to accommodate
the horses and stunt performers who
would be working in the arena set number
four is this where we do science when we
look at this giant Construction in this
huge Warehouse we're reminded more of a
science facility at Nasa than a world of
dragons and drama even hearing the
production staff talk about this monster
sounds more like something from a Sci-Fi
it's that next evolution of the ability
to see your visual effects live in
camera while you're
say that this is what the world of House
of the Dragon really looks like and
that's because this massive space is a
cylinder of imagination there are 2 000
video screens inside onto which the
background can be projected when filming
a scene this helps not only with
producing the amazing visuals of House
of the Dragon but it assists actors in
feeling more immersed in the action
which can make for an even better
performance number five
going nowhere fast ultimately on the set
there was just this unadorned bridge the
real-life location Dragonstone Bridge
might be impractical for filming but at
least it goes somewhere House of the
Dragon used a special technology to
capture and recreate a section of the
real-life location what we see is a long
and foggy Bridge with dragons that
circle around it what the actors see
might be similar thanks to the thousands
of video screens that surrounded this
set but the bridge only leads to the
other side of the giant room number six
Ahoy one third of this ship was actually
built for the filming of House of the
dragon and while CGI included The
Horizon the ocean and of course the
dragons there was actually a series of
fans that moved the sails and put a wind
effect onto the actor's hair and
costumes as well as a special water
cannon on set that would emulate waves
crashing against the side of the ship
and sending sea spray up into the air
and sometimes onto the actors on Deck
number seven duh doing it the simple way
might not sound like the most frequent
Choice when making House of the Dragon
but even this Fantastical production had
its exceptions Sometimes the best
solutions to a problem is the simplest
one in this scene where the CGI Dragon
swoops the deck of the ship the
challenge was to make it appear as
though the ship was tilting over
slightly in the water building a ship
was tricky enough and so for this scene
it was up to the actors to move together
as if they were losing their balance but
this isn't the first time we've seen
this kind of problem solving if you've
ever seen an episode of Star Trek this
group movement might be familiar to you
number eight gotcha it's understandable
that we might assume most of the ornate
and unusual things on screen in House of
the Dragon are created using CGI it's a
powerful tool and it gets used liberally
it does the trick of tricking us into
thinking we're looking at something real
but sometimes we get tricked twice the
collection of artifacts are rounding the
sea snake were actually made by a
talented and tricky team of set
decorators using Inspirations from
museums and the real world you would
take a treasure from each place and
that's what kind of became a big part of
his set and most of it was made from
insulation foam that had been carefully
carved and painted number nine they are
anything but two-dimensional filming
large crowd scenes with hundreds of
actors in costume and in character can
be a daunting task there are plenty of
considerations to be made and each take
can be a difficult one to coordinate
with the long list of details to follow
adding the restrictions that come with
filming during a pandemic didn't make
things any simpler with having 150
background performers on set the team
had to get creative so where we have to
put crowd into a shot that doesn't have
enough crowd in it they filmed some
sections of the crowd together and for
the rest they pulled each background
performer aside and got them to perform
a few actions in front of a green screen
the team then used computer Graphics to
fill out their rest of the crowd with
these card people number 10. when are we
we started shooting one year and we
finished a year later the claim your
dragon scene took seven months to film
and most of it was done on either end of
those seven months this could be a
challenge for actor Leo Ashton who would
need to recall the details of his
performance after such a long time the
visual effects team was faced with the
challenge of concealing that Leo had
aged visibly and keeping this from being
apparent when cutting between takes
shots seven months apart number 11 from
hand drawing to computer graphics and
Back Again shooting on the Targaryen
Flagship found the production team
following what might seem like an odd
procedure first they designed the ship
then they animated it planned out the
actor and camera movements using
computer graphics and then they built
the ship only to start all over again by
shooting live actors on the ship set and
then going back and doing more CGI there
must have been a method to their Madness
because we think the end result is
fantastic number 12 my what big dragon
you have one of the concepts of the
House of the Dragon series is that
dragons keep growing as they get older
when they are very young they can fit
comfortably perched on your shoulder as
they age they eventually become too
large to even fit through a door but
this dragon is something else vagar is
130 years old which means she's one big
dragon certainly the large Dragon you've
ever seen on Game of Thrones in fact
she's so big that she doesn't fit into
most places in her world anymore working
with an imaginary creature of that size
must have been hard to imagine but the
societal gives us an idea of just how
large this creature is meant to be
number 13. this might be the largest
dragon ever ridden on screen before with
the bigger dragon comes bigger movements
in order to make the riding the dragon
scene work the team had to design a
special saddle that would emulate the
movements of the dragon as well as
allowing after Leo Ashton to ride on it
while performing the scene this
specially built machine was made to read
the pre-production visual sketches of
the seen and produce them as a sort of
mechanical bull ride this machine also
had to accurately re-perform each
movement in order to get multiple takes
of the scene without any mismatches
number 14 point not taken while the
background and most of the crowd might
be added in later using the magic of
cinema this scene from the stadium has
an element of reality that everyone on
set could feel that day those horses are
real and those Riders are actually
jousting they used a few special pieces
of equipment and had a lot of training
of course stunt jousters use special
Lance is made of lightweight wood that
has been cut lengthwise along the
desired shatter point and painted to
look like they're solid while a
real-life jouster would aim for the body
of the opponent the stun performers aim
to hit each other's Shields with the
special lances when they impact just
right the Lance breaks apart in an
impressive explosion of wood splinters
and with minimal impact to the stunt
performers number 15 it's not all CGI
with this show being so closely
connected to Game of Thrones the
production team set out to make the
audience feel like they were watching
the same show but it seems they also set
out to make the actors feel like they
were really in the world of House of the
Dragon you read the script at home and
you imagined the scene and then when you
come in it's always twice the size you
imagined it some of these wonderfully
crafted locations have been built from
the ground up by the production team but
others are Real historic places in life
House of the Dragon actor Eve best said
you walk around these sets that look
like ancient monuments and buildings
with massive statues or you can be on
these amazing locations you cannot
believe that this is on the earth
somewhere this extraordinary while the
visual effects team says they held back
this season we think they are off to a
strong start the sets seem to be just as
impressive as the in-show locations
which house of the Dragon location real
or VFX would you like to visit most let
us know in the comments below
foreign